hey what's up i'm on here i'm in there
i'm sorry
okay who's in gary's house lucas who was
a
a loser lucas i don't think you should
go to school do you know that they're
closing
around school he's already been up and
back oh really and you're
and you're hugging him i know you're
supposed to have a conversation about
this he's supposed to go get a test
uh oh now i've got covered and toe
fungus
i know put in a mask gary in your own
home
is that him is that lucas there he is
there's typhoid mary get over here now
he has a mask
lucas touch my headphones with your
grimy fists
lucas i love your father you're a great
kid why would you
why would you come in from the outside
after you've been with your you know
your college situation
i don't understand what you just did it
was it was honestly just impulse
um hello hello yeah but but you know
better i mean you're a bright guy
you know better than two last week and
you said i know how to be careful
yeah yeah honestly that just kind of
wasn't smart i kind of wasn't thinking
yeah and why would you go off to college
i told you not to go why would you go
off to college and then run right home
the following weekend i mean why are you
back already
uh well i actually i i have to go pick
up a u-haul and get like the rest of my
stuff oh you're still gonna try this
yeah you know i'm going for it um i will
say i'm pretty freaked out like
as soon as i got there there's just ten
guys shirtless
playing beer pong in our driveway like
at this point we were just like
oh just not gonna last long you you're a
young guy
you might have kovit right now and be
asymptomatic
you literally could have just given your
father covid and he's no spring chicken
seriously yeah i i
i'm very sorry i wasn't really thinking
honestly
coming soon gary's obituary
and lucas gary's already coughing did
you just see that
i'm being serious he just coughed
what was that clearing of the throat
no nothing going on you know what gary's
downfall is he's he's a great dad
everybody wants to hug him he's too nice
but lucas you're a young guy you know
you gotta think about the
your dad's older you know what i mean
yeah yeah no
i i totally agree with you um i'm sorry
dad
did you wash that hand i did i did i
sanitized
and i i will use these hands to write
you a very good eulogy
don't be idiots like me all right